[Music]
anyone who's played a mario party game
in the past 20 years has a good idea of
what to expect from switches Super Mario
Party the Nintendo's latest offers a few
new modes that each at their own
creative spin on the tried and true
formula the fierce competitive nature of
the series earliest titles is back as
Super Mario Party ditches Mario Party 9
and tens cooperative car mechanic and
once again pits players against each
other in a race for stars
the overall goal in Super Mario Party is
to earn 5 gems would you get after
completing each of the games five major
offline modes Mario Party mode features
the series classic formula of bite-sized
games interspersed between rounds of
four-game hijinks the biggest change is
the introduction of character dice
blocks while previous mario party games
utilized virtual 10-sided dice now every
character has two dice blocks one
six-sided and the other unique to them
you have to decide which one to use each
turn for the first time in a Mario Party
game your choice of character is more
than just aesthetic and figuring out the
best time to use a specific dice block
adds a level of strategy to what's
typically been an act of randomness each
of the games for boards requires slight
tweaks to your strategy for reaching the
star but they're all small and don't
feel distinct and since there are only
four in total
Mario party mode grows stale fairly
quickly there are 80 minigames in Super
Mario Party and nearly half rely on the
motion control or Rumble features and
the switches joy cons don't worry
both the motion and Rumble features work
surprisingly well it makes for some of
the most cleverly designed games in the
Mario Party series in nutcases for
example you determine a box's contents
by picking it up and measuring the
severity of your joy Kahn's vibration
the drawback to this is that since Super
Mario Party only supports motion and
Rumble control with a single joy con you
won't be able to play the game in
handheld mode or with a pro controller
partner party mode a super mario party's
reimagining of mario party sixes team
battle mode although similar to mario
party mode and partner party there are
more paths around the board and you need
to actually land onto that spot to get a
star instead of just collecting it while
passing by the minor obstacles from
mario party mode becomes trickier to get
past and partner party because you need
to remain mindful of both you and your
partner this type of consideration and
amount of forethought simply doesn't
exist in mario party mode
two of the other major modes River
survival and soundstage are completely
new to the mario party franchise the
former has you working together with
three others to survive a trip down a
dangerous river while playing co-op
minigames while the latter is an
energetic dance competition where you
slowly play rhythm minigames both co-op
and rhythm minigames lack the heated
competition of other head-to-head
minigames but they do pump up a room
[Music]
super mario party's final major mode
challenge road is the closest the game
has to a single-player campaign you play
through every single minigame with
specific handicaps placed on you to make
each one harder this mode comes very
close to giving Super Mario Party just
the amount of challenge that the game
would need to increase its longevity but
unfortunately you can just skip certain
minigames with no consequence and still
beat the entire road
Super Mario Party also has several
smaller modes and features that aren't
tied to earning the Super Start title
and Mario thon you compete in five
minigames online or off where outlasting
your opponents and time based games earn
two extra points on the tournament
ladder square-off
is also a mini game based tournament but
after each win you're allowed to claim a
territory space the winner is whoever
owns the most spaces at the end of the
match both modes give you a goal to
strive for while playing minigames which
creates extra levels of competition
amongst a group of friends there's also
toads rec room where you can play unique
games that changed based on how you
position your switch and a stickers room
where you can cover a wall in the mural
of stickers you can earn or a lock
through scanning and amiibo although the
option of changing perspectives and
toads rec room is an interesting gimmick
none of the games are really made better
by adjusting how you look at them the
stickers room is not worth it getting
invested as it's just a means to sell
more amoebas it's in Super Mario parties
varied assortment of 80 minigames or
you'll find most of your fun especially
if you've got a full group of three
people to play against it's unfortunate
that mario party mode begins to feel
stale after a while but the new partner
party River survival and soundstage
modes are enjoyable alternatives and
even if the unique character dice blocks
don't drastically changed the game they
do implement small moments of strategy
into a series that has for too long
solely relied on randomness to determine
a winner
[Music]